people always like to ask me what is it
that a producer
does I like to reply I
produce and that doesn't mean I just pay
for it though I
do I'm the one who gives birth to it
all it's what I've always wanted to do
it's what I've always done well tell him
if he can't write a song that sounds
like Andrew Lloyd we I'll call someone
else I'll call Andy Weber that's
who Carl ma'am we're going to need you
to push now I got to go just get it
done I've won nine
Tony I've given birth to 34 Broadway
shows but if someone asks me what my
favorite thing I've ever made is Mama
Mia hands down change the trajectory of
my whole
career that's a joke producers can be
funny people don't realize that I'm your
mommy I'll protect you for the rest of
your
[Music]
life hey
Carl tell him the song should be called
the rest of your
life it's about a parent imagining a
life for their
child
the thing no one tells you when you
first start is how rewarding producing
can
be
or how dangerous yeah but I should suris
to see I know who you are you know it's
so incredibly exciting to be invited
into the inner sanctum like this
watching you3 work I imagine it's like
being inside that documentary watching
uh Paul McCartney write get back yeah
that's why they call us the RO R in
stones of True Crime no it's the Beetles
I was kidding okay and thank you for
yesterday for stopping me from pleading
guilty to Ben's murder well we know that
you were just trying to protect Dicky
your son and thank you for bailing me
out I paid your bail yes but when they
said they didn't take MX I helped you
find your Visa anything for you me more
my peepot My Little Cuddle
pups
e is this what this looks like you don't
call tobert Cuddle pups I have a hard
enough time calling him tobert the
documentary guy are you in hate oh nice
thanks I know right so are we sure about
Donna on opening night Donna got her
hands on an early review and it was a
pan a massacre the harshest review in
the history I have had like six heart
attacks this season Charles can we move
past the shitty review and just recap
what we know
okay so Donna can't let her son's first
show be a bomb due to Ben so she shreds
the review finds the rat poison makes a
poisonous cookie and gives it to him a
cookie she knows that he can't resist
due to his deep seated eating disorder
and in fact it was my unhealthy
relationship to dips that helped us
crack
it leave me alone I'm happy I'll get
help but the poison didn't kill Ben so
Donna takes things a step further she
pushes him down the Elevator Shaft at
Oliver's Afterparty admittedly it's a
pretty drastic step for her she had to
have been
sick
she's
[Music]
sick and if she only has a limited
amount of time to ensure her son's
future I tell you a mother will do
almost anything it's good but it's thin
we don't have anything tying Donna to
the push we need a confession on tape it
it's what we do and on opening night
okay let's go over the plan let's start
with the bouquet of flowers can we tweak
these yeah I did these really fast the
Oliver lines on card three I think I
should take them you don't think I can
say those oh no you could but I think I
can do more with it in what way how
could you do well just it needs to be so
real and so believable when I have a
more experience at it is it always like
this this is us on
fire hey do you know when you're going
to tell
Dicky I just want to get through opening
night and then I'm going to tell him
right afterwards Oh
yay that was a weird thing to fist pump
on yeah it was odd oh Dicky showed me
something when he came to visit me after
my arrest I have it you know what I I
think we should lose all your lines on
card n i mean if we want Donna to
confess before curtain we need cuts and
you tend to milk your stuff me milk my
stuff oh that's right that's what I do
yep I milk everything oh look at me oh
I'm milking bossy the cow milk milk milk
oh look at all the milk I'm
getting okay you got a point Dicky was
worried that this might implicate me
but might this tie Donna to the
push what
did I do
[Music]
good